I cry every time my mother says she's
proud of my weight loss she still
doesn't know I mentor x''k
never my boyfriend's use my body I'm
scared Lee he'll notice I'm anorexic I
tell people I'm on a liquid diet what
they don't realize is that I'm anorexic
and the only liquid in my diet is water
I have anorexia my head keeps telling me
pretty girls don't eat I'm anorexic I
hate myself for the passion the only
time I eat is when I'm going drinking
because being drunk is the only thing
that takes away the pain I only eat in
front of my parents so they won't find
out I'm interact sick and send me to
recovery I tell everyone I'm losing
weight because they exercise but the
truth is I'm anorexic I'm anorexic and
I'm trying to get better I can't stand
that every restaurant displays calories
it's so triggering I denied the fact
that I have anorexia today I saw my
sister start to hate on her body the way
I do she's eight this really hit home I
need to change for her sake I recovered
from anorexia four years ago I used to
pray to God that he would let me die
most surviving has made me a stronger
person I'm proud of who I've become